said to the six five two waters theorem
how can I write that are the seats cos
theta plus I sine six okay now what's
the negative 64 in monarch form remember
modulus is just the distance right so I
would you should say that in positive
terms 64 what angle do I measure if I'm
at minus 64 right I've got to go from
the positive real axis all the way over
to - sister force there's PI radians
okay so I put this five carried out
excuse me
from this I can read off the modulus
right
what's the magis equal to what the have
six equals six to do it's just - okay
so therefore now equating real imaginary
parts right and I can say cause on six
theta equals two
plus my cable bye
my husband is that just gonna work out
okay now remember I have to write the
other one as well sign six theta equals
sine PI but I know based on what
happened over here right this is going
to give me too many solutions it's going
to give me too many so I can kind of
ignore him really the business end is
happening over here okay now remember
the first solution is where these two
aims are just the same angle right so I
can just say six theta equals PI but
that's not the only solution
super because what's it a period of its
supine right so I can add 2 pi I can add
4 PI and 6 PI so I'll say 2 K PI where K
is any integer value all right because I
can go the other way as well the other
way okay so now I just have to divide
through I just want to feed up after all
so I could say theta equals what am I
got my right hand side close your tie on
6 plus I've got 2 K PI on 6 which is a
PI on 3 okay that was a lot quicker
because we didn't have to talk through
the mechanics of why okay so you can see
now I've got my modulus I've got every
different argument that I want okay so
let's go through them all right when K
equals 0 I always start with your cuz
that's the easiest one to work out I'm
going to get a solution said 1 right
let's quickly give it a go I've got it -
yes
excuse me no and the reason why is
because of what happened over here but
it's going to give you too many
solutions it's gonna give you some
solutions that you must reject on the
base do you always size this part not
not really that's all you need really it
will give you the same set of solutions
anyhow
and when you had posed to K PI you get
all the answers okay now I'm doing it
more hard for them so what's my first
angle cause all of our K 0 so this part
disappears so I just get financing okay
so everything started in rectangular
form right so I better get this back in
rectangular form as well cause pilot 6
is 3 3 M plus sine 5 6 is just ha you
multiply your factor 2 through and you
get this guy okay now where is this guy
what is this guy I'm gonna keep three
three plus I he's two units from the
origin right and he's piling 6 radians
pop okay now can you see why that has to
be that's just quickly joining
okay so where is root 3 + i3 g + 9 is
gonna be somewhere about there is it 1
okay yeah think about what happens when
I take this guy and I racing through the
power of 6 thinking what happens right
first let's think about the moduli the
modulus at the moment is - right
so when I do it six times it'll go to 4
8 16 32 64 they'll take me out really
far what about the angle what will
happen to the angle maybe politics and I
just keep adding it right I keep adding
it so I go one two three will get me a
pilot - four five six gets me on to the
negative real axis which is a career I
better be right that's where - 64 is
just a lot further away it's only here
to try it that's where I wants to get to
it was to get to this argument I think
it doesn't need to go all the way around
let's try the next value K equals 2 that
would give me sorry K equals 1 that
would give me a new complex root right
then - all right sounds a bit tricky up
I've got my modulus at this front cause
off ok pilot 6 + pi/3 my own 6 that's 3
PI on seeks which is my on TV okay cause
pine - of course is cause pylon to of
course is 0 + sine PI 2 sine PI 2 is
just 1 the tank oops I'm sorry I'm
multiplying later so that's assuming I
come - I wish to life twice the same
distance from the origin as said one is
my Z - 2 I
why did this work yes good question
we'll come to that in a second
is it to like I just put in cables one
night that's where they ended to see why
it works what's gonna happen when I do
it six times what happened the angle
there we go first time second third or
fifth sixth I'm on the negative real
axis and of course the modulus does its
thing and becomes 64 away from you
ordered that make sense okay let's try
the next I'll say yeah we'll get to it
else I'll show you why I would choose to
go to a negative and a certain point
okay
so k equals to 7 3 equals there's my
modulus cars off okay guys help me out
with my own six plus two point that's
five point six right okay maybe you need
to recalculate not this one this one yes
one hundred and fifty so where are you -
Route three on two plus signs my pile of
six that's the same as side politics
because country I which is uh huh okay
what's this complex eyeball minus root 3
plus I where is that well that's this
guy right over there there's it three
three plus I in fact he's out he's the
reflection across the imaginary axis
okay now at this point I stopped
increasing K I'm gonna go around to the
other side try negatives how do I know
her to try negative now
yes yes very good so you can see what's
happening to the item is eachother
pi16 and in Pilot 2 and then 5 PI over 6
you can see like you are the diagram
when I add the next one I'm gonna go to
pashed where I'm PI I should be a
negative PI right so instead of going
anti-clockwise I'm now going to come
around the other side and do all of the
negative cases ok
I'll save you a bit of time you're going
to get this shape it's not unity it's
something else special which which I'm
going to do with in detail later okay so
I've got I've got is in forever here
then finally here ends in see us okay
I'm you can go through you can cut you
scrunch the different values okay you'll
get K equals negative 1 here k equals
negative two papers negative 3 that will
give you those answers now have the same
arguments but in Reverse so what do we
gather from this how would you describe
in the same way that we described it
before what binds all of these solutions
together they're all 2 units away from
the origin right which means they all
sit on a circle of radius 2 right and
they are still evenly spaced out now
quick question I got asked how can we
skip something right
how can we skip the name of seems like
it might be here right I'm guessing if
this is PI L 6 PI on to this would be PI
on 3 PI on 3 what would happen if I
tried I on 3
remember I'm gonna do it six times right
so if I win I on three here okay hi on
three once you multiply to 6 times is
too high so in fact you're not gonna end
up on the negative real axis which is
what you really want you're actually
going to spin back round to the positive
real axis which is ugly that's the
really right and just going through the
cases for the values of K will tell you
what the my argument
okay questions on that this process it's
gonna work exactly the same regardless
of what number you're working at the
complex roots all okay so for instance
you could just as easily work out this
okay okay so you've got this number oh
it's almost it's the opposite one over
there okay you can work out its me
through it's going to be five times
closer to the origin and a will be five
times smaller and all of the extra ones
that you're going to get once you take
the different names of care of it